boom dusters paleo ale is beer made from
a 35 million year old whale fossil and
this face aging progression uses
thousands of online photos of people the
same age to show you what your toddler
will look like in 80 years Vsauce Kevin
here
this is my flow
three London design students have
created edible water bottles the blobs
called low-cost only two cents to make
are hygienic and biodegradable the water
is held inside a double membrane made
from algae and calcium chloride that
works similar to an egg yolk the hopes
are that this can one day be a
substitute for the large amount of water
bottles thrown away every year but
packaging is currently a challenge
Suda labs is creating a miniature mobile
printer they shrunk the size of a
traditional printer by moving the
printhead onto a small omni wheel system
that runs across the page its battery
charge connects directly to a smart
device or PC and prints on any size
paper each ink cartridge can print a
thousand pages and you simply line up
the corner of the device to the corner
of the paper to ensure that the print is
straight biomedical engineers at Duke
have grown living skeletal muscles that
heal themselves it's the first time that
engineered muscle has been able to
contract as strongly as native skeletal
muscle native muscles have stem cells
known as satellite cells on reserve to
start regenerating muscle as soon as an
injury happens the key to this latest
success was creating micro environments
where the satellite cells could sit and
wait until they were needed to prove the
engineered muscles ability they injected
it with snake venom to see if the
satellite cells would activate and
repair the damaged muscle and they're
looking to discover if this new
technology can repair actual muscle
injuries and disease Stanford engineers
are creating a video game controller
that senses emotions and adjusts the
gameplay depending on how you feel they
measure pulse and respiration rate as
well as how much the player's hands are
moving so for instance if your heart
rate goes down the game could send in
more zombies to make it more exciting or
if the parents are worried their kids
are getting too amped up they can have
the game set to slow down in that
instance the body dryer is a bacteria
free drawing system that eliminates the
need for towels after choosing between
hot or cold air it takes only 30 seconds
to fully dry by forcing super compressed
ionized air up and the water down off
your
badi Reza Montez ami of Iowa State is
developing dissolvable electronics he
and his team have created a degradable
antenna that is capable of data
transmission and they hope this
technology can lead to future medical
devices that melt inside the body or
military devices that dissolve if
information gets into the wrong hands
this urban vegetable garden can grow 970
square meters of produce in only 16
square meters the LED lights help grow
plants faster using a system that can
control the illumination strength
depending on the stage of the plant
reducing an average two and a half month
growth period down to only one month and
the technology has been in place since
2010 but is now being installed
regularly in Japan the pl0 one is a tank
concept that can turn invisible to
infrared detection using hexagonal
plates that cover the exterior that
control the temperature of the tank to
match the surrounding heat signature
this way the tank seems invisible to
infrared targeting sensors that are
often mounted on drones and missiles and
the functional prototype is due in 2016
a 23 hour surgery resulted in a woman
receiving a 3d printed plastic skull it
was the first time an entire cranium was
replaced with the plastic skull implants
were previously made by hand using a
cement-like material but 3d printing
allows surgeons to make more precise
prosthetics that can be designed down to
the cellular level which significantly
lowers the risk of the body rejecting
them finally slow life by Daniel stupid
speeds up the constant but unnoticed
movement of coral and sponge marine life
I'm gonna leave you with the dynamic
machine driven shape display that
visualizes streams of data
for more incredible virus footage check
out five reasons why viruses make the
perfect villain over on head steam while
you're there make sure you subscribe and
as always thanks for watching